pendant on va aller donc à mayotte et on
se pose une question ce soir que va
proposer manuel macron matière de lutte
contre l'immigration clandestine
on devrait le savoir dans quelques
minutes ou d'ici ce soir puisque le chef
de l'état doit de nouveau s'exprimer sur
la question sur d'autres aussi il a en
réalité multiplié les déclarations
depuis son arrivée il a déjà promis un
aéroport plus grand et aussi de dépasser
l'objectif en lisant sommaire de
renvoyer 25 mille clandestins en 2020 je
vous propose d'écouter le chef de l'état
qui est revenu également sur un autre
sujet épineux l'islam et le
communautarisme
la priorité du moment c'est de lutter
contre la radicalisation et de renforcer
notre politique de lutte contre ce qu'on
appelle le communautarisme qui est un
séparatisme dans la république au nom
d'une religion qui est perverti de ses
finalités
je me suis déjà exprimé à plusieurs
reprises sur à la fois l'islam la
laïcité
j'y reviendrai mais ça n'est pas au
moment où nous lançons ces débats nous
avons les avancées qu'on doit se
replonger dans des débats qu'on a déjà
visité des centaines de fois
raphaël enthoven ça correspond à vos
attentes oui tout à fait sur le
communautarisme sur le fait là bas la
valorisation comme tel d'une
appartenance qui serait un séparatisme à
l'intérieur de la république je n'ai pas
mieux à dire effectivement c'est la
meilleure définition qu'on puisse en
donner et c'est l'ennemi numéro 1 d'une
communauté nationale c'est à dire que
c'est là c'est le lutter contre le
communautarisme c'est lutter contre le
fait qu'une communauté se prennent pour
une fin en soi mais c'est aussi défendre
le principe d'égalité qui transcende
justement les appartenances particulière
donc oui là pour le coup rien à dire
rien de plus que ce que le président a
déclaré rien à dire alexis qu'il faut
dire c'est ce qu'avance avance la
question à laquelle répond oui c'est
très intéressant la question occupe à
laquelle il répond c'est est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec jean michel blanquer
quand il dit que le voile n'est pas
souhaitable pour la france et il répond
pas et il veut pas répondre et ai dit
non mais c'est pas le sujet ont j'en
parle j'en ai déjà parlé j'en parlerai
une autre fois on est là
effectivement cette intéressante c'est
donc en creux c'est ce qu'il ne dit pas
qui me paraît intéressant parce que on
peut adhérer tout à fait aux positions
que jean michel blanquer air et trouvé
que les mots de souhaitable était
malheureux donc c'est en tout cas de la
part du président de la république c'est
quand même intéressant de voir à deux
reprises heures qu'on lui demandait ce
que vous a trouvé les paul et paul de
paroles de michel jean michel blanquer
il dit pas oui pas franchement oui il ya
on en reparlera il faut lutter contre le
communautarisme et il faut pas
stigmatiser parce qu'après il rajoute
mais il faut pas stigmatiser et dit
d'ailleurs il ne faut pas aborder ce
sujet après des dérapages des palmes aux
dérapages en fait après en réponse au
front national
donc c'est quand même un moyen de
désavouer jean michel blanquer grosso
modo il fallait pas que jean-michel
bancaire on parle à ce moment là enfin
dire pardon voir un désaveu de jean
michel blanquer dans l'idée que le
communautarisme est inséparable dans la
république me semble un peu excessif
le directeur malgré tout le cas c'est à
dire que quand on demandait ce que vous
l'approuvez le truc se dire bah oui je
suis directement ministre ça là il le
dit pas et quand on leur demande d'être
fils parce que vous êtes d'accord qu'ils
ne le dit pas non plus donc il ya quand
même on sent bien qu'un et sorte de
malaise autres cette question et que les
déclarations de jean-michel blanquer moi
j'approuve après obligé d approuver mais
en tout cas créé un malaise au sein du
gouvernement et que entre au milieu et
macro et doit flip ne veulent pas
tranché le cil bon d'accord moi je veux
dire une chose c'est pas forcément
présent de la république d'être d'accord
avec son ministre de l'éducation
nationale moi j'ai un point de vue
étroitement hiérarchique là dessus je
pense que jean michel blanquer avant de
s'avancer sur ce genre de sujet il
aurait mieux fait de se coordonner avec
le président de la république
la deuxième chose c'est que là on parle
non pas de la france enfin on parle d'un
département enfin date n'en on parle
d'un territoire qui est devenue
département français en 2011 et qui est
dans une situation assez différente sur
le plan de la place qu'ils occupent
l'islam et des difficultés qui tiennent
à la fois aux inégalités à une
immigration clandestine ya pratiquement
50% d'étrangers à mayotte donc
évidemment un président de la république
ça fait des discours dans un contexte
c'est pas au fond ni un philosophe ni un
journaliste c'est quelqu'un qui parle
dans un contexte en s'adressant on va le
dire il s'adresse pas peut-être à des
communautés mais s'adresse aussi à des
gens qui attendent quelque chose en
terme de clientèle dont qu'il l'aï dit
quelque chose de ferme mais c'est moins
compliqué de le dire à mayotte fermement
que de le dire sur l'école de la
république française et la deuxième
ce que je veux dire c'est qu'ils me
semble que sur la question de l'islam de
l'islamisme du terrorisme il ya un
moment il faut aussi mieux différencier
les choses moi par exemple j'ai été très
critique sur le fait qu emmanuel macron
par le d'idriss la ministre dans son
discours parce que là j'ai trouvé que
c'était extrêmement abstrait et qu'on
attend d'un président de la république
pour le coup qui disent des choses
fortes en termes de politiques publiques
sur ce que disait lucile justement sur
le fait que jean michel blanquer aurait
dû se concerter avec emmanuel macron
n'ont certes pas un public les omd pour
des missions des responsables publics la
crise disent ce qu'ils pensent
et oui car isis que le voile ne leur
paraît pas souhaitable pour la france
la version la proposition aurait dû lui
aurait-il dû dire que le voile était
souhaitable pour la france évidemment le
bon ballon mais il ya comme ça devrait
maintenant posée je réponds sur ce sujet
il me semble que lorsqu'on est ministre
on est on est pas amenées à exprimer ses
positions de personnes et je pense que
j'aurai ensemble je pense que jean
michel blanquer à mélanger la position
assise dessus dionnet les impositions
part hier soir de cette position est
celle parfaitement votre droit et je le
respecte mais il faut pas lui dénier le
droit lui de l'avoir c'est sa position
il n'y a aucune différence entre jean
michel blanquer dont vraiment je
j'approuve les positions et pardonnez
moi je dis il n'y a aucune différence
entre jean michel blanquer requis qui
parle de souhaitable pas souhaitable qui
à mon avis est un mot malheureux dans la
bouche d'un ministre parce qu'il exprime
quelque chose de plus singulier de plus
individuelle qu'une position
ministérielle ou éminente et jean marc
ayrault qui parlait de minables à propos
de de gérard depardieu et du
comportement fiscal de gérard depardieu
c'est à dire dans les deux cas une
position éminente est une position qui
ce qui se comprend mais un peu kiki dont
le lexique soudain n'est pas celui qu'on
attend de sa fonction c'est la seule
critique qu'on puisse faire à l'encontre
il me semble en l'occurrence les besoins
d'une très grande simplicité de dire le
il dit très précisément la loi
n'interdit que ce n'est pas à cette
personne de porter un voile dans une
enceinte d'un conseil régional alors
qu'elle lui interdit dans le cadre de
l'ancienne l'assemblée nationale la loi
ne viendrait pas
mais dit il mais pour autant je
considère que le vol n'est pas
souhaitable dans ce bilan de sam break
mais vous mais vous n'êtes pas d'accord
avec ce qu'il dit mais c'est ma revanche
avec le parc est parfaitement clair on
va dire que c'est parce que
l'institutionnel nous voilà ce que je
ressens non je crois pas je suis le tac
sur ce qu'a déclaré emmanuel macron oui
je suis je en fait je ne suis pas sûr
qu'ils aient pas un jeu effectivement
qui est un jeu bien orchestré entre les
entre les deux personnages c'est à dire
que le président de la république je
trouve tient sa position de président de
la république dans une situation qui
quand même
enfin sur une question qui est
extrêmement complexe et extrêmement
difficile en ce moment puisque on se
rappelle que la l'histoire du voile du
du conseillère elle intervient quand
même dans un moment où il ya eu quatre
morts égorgés plus ou moins engorgés à
la préfecture de police de paris donc
c'est gilles kepel qui rappelaient
qu'ils avaient toujours des petits
événements annexes qui venait détourner
l'attention de ce qui est central
c'est-à-dire ceux le problème du
terrorisme
alors bien entendu je ne suis pas du
tout en train de dire que les musulmans
sont tous des terroristes mais en
revanche que ces petits événements sont
montés en montée en épingle d'une
certaine manière à mon avis de manière
un peu excessive
alors maintenant jean michel branquart
at il utilisé le vendeur je suis pas sûr
du tout mais je crois qu'on était à
mayotte donc est ce que je dois revenir
à mayotte non parce que c'est la
question
on était à mes yeux je vois ces dégâts
sont là il ya une déclaration quand même
sur jeu pour revenir à ce qui est dit
ce qu'a dit emmanuel macron dans
l'extrait convient d'entendre c'est qu'
il n'était pas pour l'instant question
pour lui de faire un discours et de
parler sur la laïcité mais surtout je
trouve que c'est bien qu'ils prennent de
la hauteur d'une certaine manière le
président de la vème république a la
possibilité de prendre de la hauteur
je trouve que pour une fois qu'on ne
peut pas lui reprocher dire de des
petites phrases parfois très facile à
sortir de leur contexte c'est plutôt une
bonne non sur la question de la laïcité
il y a malgré tout malgré tout malgré
des tentatives louable je dois dire de
la part du président de la république
une indécision qu'il n'a jamais tout à
fait tranché entre ce qu'il appelle une
laïcité de confrontation et une laïcité
d'abstention très clairement le
président de la république ici navigue
aussi entre deux eaux m'enfin là sur la
radicalisation sur le communautarisme
encore une fois moi je refuse que ferait
bien jolie l'acteur de dire qu'il est
contre radicalisation le communautarisme
personnes ignoraient de la vertu à dire
qu'on est d'accord avec lui quand on
n'est pas sur le reste à l'approuver en
sommes voilà avec le fait alors moi je
vais vous dire ce j'approuve absolument
de dire qu'on est contre leur a dit
qu'il donnerait des questions le
communautarisme évidemment mais je pense
surtout que la question maintenant c'est
plus tellement les mots tels que viacom
cette main alors là je vous rejoins ce
que dit lucie l'instant est une espèce
de maladie dans ce pays chez les
responsables politiques chez les
journalistes surtout sur ces questions
d'immigration de penser que la parole
performative de croire que parce qu'on a
dit les choses on a résolu des problèmes
encore moins quand on est aux manettes
au pouvoir quand le pouvoir les gens si
on a vous ont ils eu c'est pour faire
les choses et donc il c'est très
intéressant de faire l'exégèse des
paroles et des discours
ce qu'on attend en matière d'une part
d'immigration d'autre part d'islamistes
radicalisation ce qu'on attend ce
qu'attendent les français ce sont des
actes alors quand vous discutez c'est
bien c'est pas bien mais indéfiniment
attendre et et commentés et commentée
des paroles ce que je crains de ce on
attend il va parler là la caisse
me semble-t-il c'est va-t-il annoncer
des décisions ou va-t-il se contenter de
grands discours
si c'est encore des grands discours on
dit ça sert absolument à rien il ya une
chose qui me semble assez assez forte
c'est que déjà emmanuel macron a dit que
sur la question de l'immigration qui
ferait mieux qu'avant mais là où je suis
assez critique pour le coup c'est que
pourquoi pas sur la reconduite à la
frontière et sait c'est que là pour le
coup il va se heurter un principe de
réalité c'est qu'il ya 50% de personnes
qui habitent à mayotte qui sont en fait
des étrangers des comoriens que 1 48%
lors du barça ça vous ira cher vincent
48% et il se trouve que mayotte qui fait
partie de l'archipel des comores tout en
étant un département français
c'est un problème c'est une réalité
géographique donc il va reconduire à la
frontière mais jamais ne tarira les flux
d'immigration et rappelons nous qu on a
quand même oser il ya quelques mois où
vous proposez non mais attendez proposé
que par exemple la maternité où naissent
les enfants puissent est placé en statut
d'extraterritorialité alors qu'elle est
dans un département français donc on
voit bien là combien le principe de
réalité géographique s'impose de fait
aux hommes politiques donc il peut
toujours reconduire la frontière mais y
aura toujours autant de migrants et il y
aura beaucoup de naissances et y'aura
inexorablement qui est étrange là
d'accord donc la question c'est comment
on fait ce qu'il faut faire par rapport
à moi je pense quelque chose attendait
justement je ne sais pas si je peux oser
la rétrospective mais je rappelle avec
nicolas sarkozy en 2011 a décidé d'en
faire un département pour des raisons
électorales je voudrais quand même
rappeler que pour moi c'était une erreur
grossière comme elliott avait vocation à
rester un territoire d'outre-mer et non
pas département et que du coup avec
cette espèce d'ambiguïté enfin de
décision politicienne
on se retrouve dans une situation qui
est inextricable maintenant c'est une
région ultrapériphérique 1 c'est avec
beaucoup de financements européens
alors je voulais juste rajouté une
petite chose c'est que sur mayotte en
fait c'est très intéressant sur le plan
sur le plan de l'exemple
en europe parce que c'est vraiment une
frontière européenne en fait c'est toute
la difficulté des frontières européennes
avec les avec les pays plus pauvres
la question de l'immigration clandestine
qui se posent la question justement de
savoir ce qu'on fait de cette de cette
immigration clandestine
le fait aussi que nous ayons quand même
deuxième espace maritime du monde grâce
à ses îles et que la france est une
grande puissance dans l'océan indien et
que ça n'est pas seulement je crois un
électorat je crois qu'il y avait aussi
cette histoire de zone économique
exclusive de nouvelles les séances de
pétrole oui c'est vrai entérite en outre
mme hermitte
voilà une promesse de jacques chirac
pourquoi as tu essayé de tenir cette
promesse de la première fois que j'ai
entendu nicolas sarkozy dire qu'il
voulait briser les os mais justement ce
match je n'ai pas sur votre parole sur
la parole présidentielle la même analyse
que vous je l'aimais parole
présidentielle sont des paroles
illocutoire le simple fait qu'on vive
dans un régime de parole est avérée par
exemple par le fait que le break site a
été votée il ya trois ans et
techniquement aujourd'hui il n'est pas
entré en application mais tout ce qui
s'est passé autour du bric site c'est la
réalité des paroles qui ont été déposés
dessus croire que la parole est
séparable de l'action me semble
illusoire c'est surtout une façon de
reprocher à un homme politique de parler
pour ne pas agir par homme de la parole
est illusoire
il faut agir en homme de pensée pensée
en action c'est lyautey qui disait ça
avant nous mais dans le cas de la parole
présidentielle
à mayotte il y a eu une parole
présidentielle tout à fait malheureuse
qu'il n'a pas tenues à mayotte mais
qu'il a tenus au début de son mandat où
il parlait des kwassa kwassa qui rament
et du comorien et moi mon regret dans
cette histoire c'est qu'il ne met pas à
profit cette visite dont le cahier des
charges est un durcissement de la
politique migratoire donc c'est évident
que il va pas aller de ce côté là
néanmoins je regrette mois peut-être le
fera t-il dans son discours qu'il ne
soit pas revenu sur cette formulation
malheureuse où il traitait des individus
comme des quantités c'est-à-dire
quantité négligeable il disait du
comorien et l'emploi de ce génie type de
ce parti tim de la part d'un président
de la république me semblait une chose
grave
je regrette que le contexte ne lui
permettent pas de faire sa propre
autocritique
j'espère qu'il le fera
vous venez de dire montre que le
discours politique est particulier c'est
à dire qu'il est trop important et ne
sais pas s'il est très important mais en
tout cas il peut se contredire à
quelques mois ou quelques années et
c'est là qu'il n'est pas effectivement
performative c'est à dire des potes oui
on dirait que la vérité du commun ils
n'étaient pas devant 500 de la vérité
c'est que le problème en politique c'est
qu'on peut tenir un discours puis le
discours inverse l'année d'après et que
du coup la question du lien avec
l'action est certainement différente de
celle de lorsqu'on est philosophe ou
lorsqu'on était un simple citoyen on se
contredit - j'ai pas politique puisse
tenir dire une chose et son contraire
exactement une année l'année suivante
jours d'intervalle quand par exemple
emmanuel macron dit l'hydre islamiste
la société de vigilance le lundi et
quatre jours plus tard le pad amalgame
pas de stigmatisation traire ça on peut
tout trouver mais enfin quand mes gardes
il n'ya pas garde il n'y a rien à bien
vous sentez bien que ses quelque 60 bien
quoi je sais bien que lutter contre
l'hydre islamiste ne suppose pas
uniquement qu'on lui coupe la tête
le propre de liszt c'est que deux têtes
repoussent partant dans coupe une le
procès volutes et construit un dire
précisément c'est de lui couper toutes
ces têtes les unes après les autres
voilà dans sa méthode camarades venir
avec un buisson et moi et jean picq à
benghazi dans mes livres
le choix de luc de la métaphore de
l'histoire de la ligue 1 de métaphores
canton guerrière est une métaphore c'est
une méthode c'est précisément celles
dont on ne coupe pas la tête c'est un
débat là ne saurions vous concluez et on
donne la parole aux internautes parce
qu'ils n'ont pas encore parlé sans pour
le rn aux élections européennes donc il
ya aussi du très pratique et c'est
peut-être là d autres aspects
effectivement de cette même sûrement
l'autre aspect de cette visite macron on
n'a pas encore compris les enjeux locaux
nous dit réaction injecter de l'argent
n'a aucun sens pour régler le problème
de sécurité fou une intervention de
l'armée
nicole
dit emmanuel macron est un grand parleur
mais un petit faiseur que fait-il
concrètement contre le communautarisme
on peut dire que ni comment ni colle et
nicole est au coeur du débat et
l'autorité républicaine rien que cette
phrase fait sourire comme s'il y avait
eu encore une autorité dans ce pays
il la caisse